Mais ce qu'on a observé, après le 11 septembre,
c'est que le secret et la justification du terrorisme ont été utilisés
pour démarrer ces programmes en cachette,
sans demander au Congrès,
sans demander au peuple américain,
et c'est ce type de gouvernement à huis clos
contre lequel il faut nous protéger,
car il dégrade notre sécurité
et n'offre aucune valeur.
CA : D'accord, venez ici avec moi un instant,
car j'ai une question plus personnelle pour vous.
A propos de terrorisme,
la plupart des gens trouveraient terrifiante
la situation qui est la vôtre en Russie.
Vous avez forcément entendu ce qui s'est passé,
le traitement reçu par Bradley Manning,
maintenant connu sous le nom de Chelsea Manning,
et il y a eu une histoire dans Buzzfeed qui disait
qu'il y a des personnes dans le monde du renseignement
qui veulent vous voir mort.
Comment vivez-vous cela ?
Comment gérez-vous cette peur ?
ES : Ce n'est pas un mystère
qu'il existe des gouvernements qui veulent me voir mort.
J'ai expliqué encore et encore et encore
que je m'endors chaque matin
en me demandant ce que je peux faire pour le peuple américain.
Je ne veux pas nuire à mon gouvernement.
Je veux aider mon gouvernement,
mais le fait qu'il soit disposé à
ignorer complètement la procédure régulière,
qu'il soit prêt à déclarer la culpabilité
sans tenir un procès,
voilà les choses contre lesquelles nous devons nous battre
en tant que société, et dire que ce n'est pas convenable.
On ne devrait pas menacer les dissidents.
On ne devrait pas criminaliser le journalisme.
Et quoi que je puisse faire pour en finir avec ça,
je suis heureux de le faire malgré les risques.
CA : Je voudrais maintenant avoir les impressions
du public
car je sais qu'il y a des réactions radicalement divergentes
à propos d'Edward Snowden.
Imaginons que vous ayez le choix suivant, d'accord ?
On pourrait voir ce qu'il a fait
comme un acte foncièrement irresponsable
qui a mis l'Amérique en danger,
ou on pourrait le voir comme un acte foncièrement héroïque
qui contribuera à mener l'Amérique et le monde
vers le bien à long terme.
Voici le choix que je vous propose.
Je suis curieux de voir qui est prêt à voter
pour la première option
celui de l'acte irresponsable ?
Des mains se lèvent,
des mains se lèvent.
C'est difficile de lever sa main
quand l'homme en question se tient juste ici,
mais j'en vois.
ES : Je vous vois. (Rires)
CA : Et qui opte pour la deuxième option,
l'acte foncièrement héroïque ?
(Applaudissements) (Acclamations)
Je crois qu'on peut dire qu'il y a de nombreuses personnes
qui n'ont pas levé la main, et qui selon moi
réfléchissent encore à leur choix
car il me semble que le débat à votre sujet
ne correspond pas aux lignes politiques traditionnelles.
Ce n'est pas la gauche ou la droite, il n'est pas vraiment question
d'être pro-gouvernement, libertaire, ou pas seulement.
Il s'agit en partie d'un problème générationnel.
Vous faites partie d'une génération qui a grandi
avec Internet, et c'est un peu comme si
vous êtes outré, presque viscéralement,
lorsque vous voyez qu'on fait une chose
qui selon vous peut nuire à Internet.
Est-ce qu'il y a une part de vérité là-dedans ?
ES : Tout à fait. C'est tout à fait vrai.
Ce n'est pas une question de gauche ou de droite.
Nos libertés fondamentales, et quand je dis nos,
je ne parle pas que des Américains,
je parle des gens du monde entier,
ce n'est pas une question partisane.
Ce sont des choses auxquelles tout le monde croit,
et il dépend de chacun de nous de les protéger,
et aux personnes qui ont vu et apprécié connu et joui
d'un Internet libre et ouvert
c'est à nous de préserver cette liberté
pour que la prochaine génération en profite,
et si nous ne changeons rien,
si nous ne nous battons pas pour changer les choses
qu'il faut réaliser pour maintenir un Internet sécurisé,
pas pour nous seulement, mais pour tout le monde
nous allons le perdre,
et ce serait une immense perte,
pas que pour nous, mais pour le monde entier.
CA : J'ai entendu le même discours récemment,
de la part du fondateur du World Wide Web,
qui est ici, je crois, Sir Tim Berners-Lee.
Tim, voudriez-vous vous approcher et nous dire,
on a un micro pour Tim ?
(Applaudissements)
Tim, ça fait plaisir de vous voir. Venez.
A quel camp appartenez-vous, au fait,
traître, héros ? J'ai une théorie là-dessus, mais --
Tim Berners-Lee : J'ai fait des réponses
plus longues à cette question, mais c'est héros
si je dois faire un choix entre les deux.
CA : Ed, je crois que vous avez lu
la proposition dont Sir Tim a parlé
d'une nouvelle « Grande Charte » pour reprendre Internet.
Est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui a du sens ?
ES : Absolument. Ma génération, j'ai grandi
non seulement en pensant à Internet,
mais j'ai aussi grandi au sein d'Internet,
et bien que je n'aie jamais imaginé avoir l'occasion
de le défendre de manière si directe et pratique
et de l'incarner de cette manière bizarre,
presque comme un avatar,
je trouve qu'il y a quelque chose de poétique dans le fait
qu'un des fils d'Internet
soit devenu proche d'Internet
en raison de son expression politique.
Je crois qu'une « Grande Charte » pour Internet
est exactement ce dont nous avons besoin.
Nous devons inscrire nos valeurs,
non seulement dans des textes mais aussi dans la structure d'Internet,
et c'est quelque chose que j'espère,
j'invite toutes les personnes du public,
pas seulement à Vancouver, mais partout dans le monde,
à y participer.
CA : Avez-vous une question pour Ed ?
TBL : Deux questions, en fait,
une question générale --
CA : Ed, vous nous entendez ?
ES : Oui, je vous entends. CA : Oh, il est là.
TBL : L'écoute électronique sur votre ligne
a créé des interférences pendant un instant.
(Rires)
ES : C'est un peu le problème avec la NSA.
TBL : Dans 25 ans,
avec du recul et en y réfléchissant,
qu'est-ce qui serait selon vous
le mieux que l'on puisse atteindre
d'après nos discussions
sur le web que nous souhaitons ?
ES : Lorsqu'on réfléchit
jusqu’où on peut aller,
je pense que c'est une question qui n'est en fait limitée
que par ce qu'on veut bien y mettre.
Je pense que l'Internet que nous avons apprécié par le passé
a été exactement ce dont nous, en tant que nation,
mais aussi comme citoyen du monde, avions besoin,
et en coopérant, en impliquant
non seulement les éléments techniques de la société,
mais aussi, comme vous l'avez dit, les utilisateurs,
les gens du monde entier qui contribuent,
à travers Internet, à travers les réseaux sociaux,
qui consultent la météo,
qui comptent dessus tous les jours, qui fait partie de leur vie,
à le défendre.
On aura non seulement l'Internet que nous avions,
mais également un meilleur Internet, un présent meilleur,
quelque chose que nous pouvons utiliser pour construire un avenir
qui sera meilleur que ce que nous espérions
et que tout ce qu'on aurait pu imaginer.
CA : Ça fait 30 ans que TED a été fondé, en 1984.
Depuis, beaucoup de discussions
ont été assez proches
de là où George Orwell s'est trompé.
Ce n'est pas Big Brother qui nous regarde.
A travers le pouvoir du web et la transparence,
nous regardons Big Brother.
Vos révélations ont en quelque sorte enfoncé un pieu
dans le cœur de ce point de vue plutôt optimiste,
mais vous croyez encore qu'il y a un moyen de faire quelque chose
à ce sujet.
Et vous aussi.
ES : Oui, il faut affirmer ici
que les pouvoirs de Big Brother ont immensément augmenté.
Il y a eu un article juridique de Yale
qui a établi une chose nommée le principe de Bankston-Soltani,
qui dit que notre espoir de vie privée est violé
lorsque les capacités de surveillance gouvernementale
deviennent moins chères d'un certain ordre de grandeur,
et à chaque fois que ça se produit, nous devons revisiter
et rééquilibrer nos droits à la vie privée.
Mais, ça ne s'est pas passé depuis
que les pouvoirs de surveillance du gouvernement
ont augmenté de plusieurs ordres de grandeur,
et c'est pourquoi nous sommes dans la situation d'aujourd'hui,
mais il y a encore de l'espoir,
car le pouvoir des individus
a également augmenté grâce à la technologie.
Je suis la preuve vivante
qu'un individu peut affronter
les adversaires les plus puissants
et les agences de renseignement les plus puissantes
du monde, et gagner,
et je crois que c'est une chose
qui doit nous faire garder espoir,
et sur laquelle nous devons nous baser
pour le rendre accessible aux spécialistes techniques
mais aussi aux citoyens lambda du monde entier.
Le journalisme n'est pas un crime,
la communication n'est pas un crime,
et nous ne devrions pas être contrôlés dans nos activités quotidiennes.
CA : Je ne sais pas vraiment comment serrer la main d'un bot,
mais j'imagine que la main est juste ici. TBL : Ça viendra très rapidement.
ES : Ravi de vous rencontrer,
et j'espère que mon sourire rend aussi bien
que le vôtre pour moi.
CA : Merci Tim.
(Applaudissements)
Le New York Times a récemment demandé votre amnistie.
Accepteriez-vous l'opportunité de revenir en Amérique ?
ES : Absolument. Sans aucun doute,
les principes qui ont été à l'origine
de ce projet
ont été l'intérêt du public
et ces principes sous-tendent
la création du journalisme aux États-Unis
et dans le monde,
et je pense que si la presse dit désormais,
nous le soutenons,
c'est quelque chose qui devait arriver,
c'est un argument puissant, mais ce n'est pas l'argument définitif,
et je crois que c'est quelque chose que le public devrait pouvoir décider.
Mais en même temps,
le gouvernement a laissé entendre qu'il veut
une sorte d'accord,
qu'il veut que je compromette
les journalistes avec lesquels je travaille,
pour revenir,
et je veux dire clairement
que je n'ai pas fait tout ça pour être en sécurité.
J'ai fait tout ça pour faire ce qui est juste,
et je ne vais pas arrêter de travailler
pour l'intérêt public,
simplement pour en profiter personnellement.
(Applaudissements)
CA : Entretemps,
grâce à Internet et cette technologie,
vous voici de retour en Amérique du Nord,
pas vraiment les États-Unis, mais au Canada, sous cette forme.
Je suis curieux, qu'est-ce que ça fait ?
ES : Le Canada est différent de ce que j'avais imaginé.
Il y fait beaucoup plus chaud.
(Rires)
CA : Chez TED, la mission est « des idées qui valent la peine d'être diffusées. »
Si vous pouviez la résumer en une seule idée,
quelle serait l'idée valant la peine d'être diffusée,
tout de suite, à cet instant présent ?
ES : Je dirais que l'année dernière a été un rappel
que la démocratie pouvait mourir derrière des portes closes,
mais en tant qu'individus, nous sommes nés
derrière ces mêmes portes closes,
et nous ne sommes pas obligés d'abandonner
notre vie privée pour avoir de bons gouvernements.
Nous ne sommes pas obligés d'abandonner notre liberté
pour être en sécurité.
Et je pense qu'en travaillant ensemble,
on peut avoir à la fois des gouvernements ouverts
et des vies privées,
et je suis impatient de travailler avec chacun,
partout dans le monde, pour voir ce qu'il advient.
Merci beaucoup.
CA : Ed, merci.
(Applaudissements)